[Musik]
hallöchen die lieben wir machen heute
eine türkische pack fleisch nach vorne
ihr könnt ihr zudem gerne reis servieren
oder nur joghurt oder ist es mit brot
auch sehr lecker aber wenn vermag ist
richtig gerne weil es geht schnell und
schmeckt total lecker ich habe hier
meine pfanne erhitzen da etwas
die genauen mengenangaben die zutaten
alles was sie wissen müssen schreibe ich
immer in die video beschreibung findet
ihr unter dem titel könnt ihr euch
direkt mit screenshot machen und
einkaufen gehen so einmal das öl
erhitzen und jetzt nehme ich mir meine
knoblauchpresse und presse da direkt
knoblauch ihr wisst ja
türkische gerichte da darf kein
knoblauch fehlen und das wird also
ungefähr eine halbe minute angedünstet
so und jetzt schnappt ihr euch rinder
hackfleisch und brachte das krümmel legt
das heißt auf einer der höheren stufen
also bei hoher hitze ungefähr drei
minuten lang unter ständigem rühren und
wänden einmal anbraten
jetzt habe ich die paprika markt auch
typisch türkische könnt ihr auch
tomatenmark nehmen und das gebe ich mir
dazu arbeitet das ein wenig ein
es dauert noch ein paar sekunden und
anschließend kommt schon unseren lauf
bzw paul sie eigentlich ein synonym
kommt schon zum einsatz zusammen mit
einer roten spitz paprika
das gebe ich jetzt auch dazu und dann
las ich das so dünnsten ich geh
niedriger mit der stufe und bedeutet
ungefähr zwei bis drei minuten
das ist halt eher im kochen so eine
gefühlssache
[Musik]
so ihr lieben jetzt kommen die gewürze
dazu salz und pfeffer sind ganz klar das
mache ich jetzt auch als allererstes
also sein schöpfer ich mag ich am
liebsten frisch gemahlen ich finde das
schmeckt man einfach raus und dann ist
ganz wichtig kreuzkümmel gemahlenem
kreuzkümmel gebe ich jetzt direkt dazu
nicht geizt da auch nicht weil
kreuzkümmel und hackfleisch also fleisch
generell sind passt ja beste kombi
direkt dazu geben dann muskatnuss ist so
muss für unser lauf also muskatnuss und
lauch passen optimal zusammen nicht so
viel also ein bisschen und jetzt habe
ich hier caprica flocken
das gibt's ja einmal die süße die
scharfe variante haben sondern ich
möchte schlafen lassen dass lima gehört
pulver super gelernt sich jetzt seine
süßen variante ganz viele nationen von
der scharfen ja ein bisschen so ein
bisschen so und jetzt gehört das ja dann
ist es im prinzip schon fertig aber es
muss ja noch ein bisschen training seien
jetzt habt ihr die wahl macht ihr seine
reihen kein problem ein bisschen sahne
bist du schön sämig viert oder zehn
frisch oder saure sahne ist ein bisschen
kalorienärmer oder etwas tun also
passierte tomaten könnte auch gerne dazu
geben ich entscheide das jetzt ganz
spontan ihr sitzen in der nächsten szene
wir nehmen heute die tomaten variante 1
verstand einfach so morbid immer genau
aber auch nur ein bisschen sondern nicht
zu flüssig sein
[Musik]
so dadurch dass ich jetzt die passierten
tomaten genommen hab gehört zur thematik
immer eine prise zucker auch wenn sie
jetzt ein herz auf das gericht also eine
prise da reingeben und das ganze
wirklich nur minuten köcheln lassen dass
es sich verbindet das es erhitzt wird
und dann ist unser leckeres türkisch
angehauchtes bericht auch schon fertig
dazu passt am besten reis oder
kartoffeln die passen auch sehr gut mehr
hat und kartoffeln und lauch perfekte
kombination ein hod wir essen heute
reist und das ganze gericht hat auch nur
zehn zwölf minuten gedauert
ja es stimmt da stimmen aber ist immer
sehr herzhaft zum frühstück gibt es auch
so wenn das ist so ein allgäuer gericht
ist es dann auch mit ganz viel peperoni
und auch mit lauch ab und zu auch sehr
lecker aber ich merke schon wir haben
noch richtig viele videos die das ganze
machen das typisch türkische diese
eierspeise männer wenn die tasten möchte
oder generell ein frühstücks rezepte
einfach in die kommentare reinschreiben
so wir können uns ist jetzt wünschen
euch auch einen guten appetit wenn es
nach macht schaut um gegen die video
beschreibung da steht alles drin was wir
wissen möchtet ansonsten den leader
indischen nach oben da lassen und mein
kanal kostenlos hier unten abonnieren
wenn ihr das nicht schon längst getan
habt dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal zurück team riskiert recht
schnell so gut
[Musik]